à la lisière d'un village à une dizaine
de kilomètres de la frontière
un lance-roquette multiple et son
pointeur qui cible les positions
ukrainiennes
nous repassons pour le filmer
à quelques 200 mètres de là Yuri veut
ignorer la guerre
[Applaudissements]
difficile pourtant de ne pas remarquer
c'est qu'on voit incessants vers la
frontière c'est donc
c'est missile grade
ce mystérieuse aide sur les blindages
dans ces quartiers habitaient à moins de
15 km de la frontière ukrainienne la
guerre a surpris les habitants en pleine
nuit juste après l'annonce de
l'intervention militaire de Vladimir
Poutine
on a appelé à 5h30 du matin et m'a dit
Poutine a annoncé qu'il y aurait la
guerre avec l'Ukraine
et une demi-heure plus tard tout cela a
commencé nous avions peur très peur
ses habitants ont été réveillés par des
hélicoptères et des bombardements
ils n'ont jamais été prévenus du fait
qu'une offensive se préparait cette
femme préfère rester anonyme moi je dois
aller vous attendions des explications
qu'on nous prévienne au moins n'ayez pas
peur nous allons ouvrir le feu mais on
nous a rien dit aucune information nous
ne savons rien du tout
depuis 2014 et le début du conflit
Vladimir Poutine démantet d'avoir envahi
une partie de l'est de l'Ukraine et
jusqu'à la dernière minute il a
concentré sa force de frappe à toutes
les frontières accessibles du pays en
prétendant des exercices
[Musique]